MARKUS KLUTE: Hello.
So with this recording
I'd like to introduce
the topic of flavor symmetry,
what we mean by that.
So when the neutron
was discovered,
it was noted that the
mass of the neutron
is very close to the
mass of the proton.
And so it seems like those two
particles are somehow related.
Even so, the electric
charge is different.
The proton is charged,
the neutron is neutral.
And you can see here that the
masses are really very, very
close, about 1 MeV or about
1% difference in mass.
So Heisenberg proposed,
and that was in the 1930s,
to regard them as two
states of the same particle.
They were really so
different that you
could think that they are
basically the same, just
a rotation from one
end to the other.
And that's exactly what
he did, considering them
as one particle, a nucleon,
where the proton is described
as a doublet, with an up
doublet, and the neutron
as a down doublet,
similar to an up
quark and a down quark in
electron and neutrino later on.
Those particles were
not known at the time.
So he introduces a new
concept, so-called isospin
or strong isospin, where
he's doing exactly the this.
He labels the proton up, and
he labels the neutron down.
So, so far, we
haven't done anything,
but introduce new labels for
new particles or particles,
new particles at the time.
But now if you assume that
the strong force is invariant
under rotations in
this isospin space,
meaning when you flip the
neutron into a proton and vice
versa, those rotations
are invariant.
The strong force is invariant
under those rotations.
That means or it
follows directly
that the isospin is conserved
in all strong interactions.
So that is what
really the conclusion
is of this introduction
of those new labels
is that isospin is conserved
under strong interactions.
So this was proposed
in the 1930s.
Again, we noticed the
symmetry in nature.
And from that symmetry,
a conservation follows.
Even so, and we can conclude
in physics cross-sections
or ratios of
cross-sections from it,
without understanding
in this case,
QCDs a strong interaction.
So this is very fascinating.
And you can just apply this
concept now to other particles,
for example, the pion.
The pion has an isospin of 1.
And there are three
pions or three states--
the 0 state, the up
state, and the down state,
which is pi plus, the
pi 0, and the pi minus.
In general, you can conclude
that the multiplicity
of your particles, as you see
the neutron and the proton,
the pi plus, the pi 0, and
the pi minus, the multiplicity
is 2 times the isospin plus 1.
Isospin equals 1 means
that the three particles
as part of the representation.
So far so good.
So later, this concept was
moved to other new particles.
Many new particles were
introduced and produced
in the emerging accelerators
and experiments on the market.
And people tried to classify
them by the isospin.
Gell, Mann, and
Nishijima empirically
observed that there's
a relation which holds,
this equation here, which
is that the charge, if you
assigned the maximum value,
I3, the third component
of the isospin, to the member of
the multiplet with the highest
charge--
in the previous example it
was the proton or the pi plus.
Then the charge of
this particle follows
from the isospin, the baryon
number, and the strangeness.
We looked at baryon number
and strangeness before.
As a reminder,
strangeness is the number
of strange quarks in
the baryon or the meson,
and the baryon number is
simply the number of baryons.
So if you just look at this,
for example, for this pion case,
we had the isospin equals
1, baryon number equals 0,
strangeness equals
0, which follows
that the maximum
charge involved is
1, which is a charge of a
positively charged proton.
So far so good.
This was empirically observed.
But once you then later discover
and develop a quark model--
this is then in the 1970s--
you can deduce this equation
directly from the assignment
of isospin to quarks, which
is rather fascinating.
Again, we don't understand
the physics fully.
But just from the
symmetry you can,
and empirically you
can deduce information
about physical systems.
However, if you try to now
extend this idea of isospin
to the complete quark model,
you find that the symmetry
starts to be broken.
It already starts to
be broken slightly,
when you include strangeness
or strange quarks.
But it's badly broken when you
include charm, bottom, and top.
And the reason can be seen here.
The up quark and the down
quark, both of the particles
making up ions and the
neutron and the proton.
And even if you
include strangeness,
the different in mass
is not very large.
So the symmetry,
the particles really
look like they're the same
particle in a different state
of the same particle.
But when you introduce other
quarks, heavier quarks, charm
and bottom, you find that the
mass difference is so large,
that the symmetries are broken.
So this concept
starts failing because
of the large mass differences,
because the symmetry is broken.
All right, so from here, we
now go to discrete symmetries.
And again, from the observation
of those symmetries,
we can deduce physics
without fully understanding
the underlying physics.